coronavirus dont on parlait à l'instant
alors que l'épidémie ne cesse de
s'étendre la planète finance prend peur
et les perspectives de croissance
mondiale sont revus à la baisse
face à la menace les banques centrales
sont à la manoeuvre sans pour autant
rassurer les marchés alors comme on
l'expliquait une nouvelle crise
économique comparable à celle de 2008 et
elle à nos portes on voit ça tout de
suite avec l l'économiste jacques sapir
bonsoir bienvenue jacques merci
stéphanie alors jacques doit-on vraiment
craindre une crise économique provoquée
par cette épidémie c'est ce que beaucoup
de gens c'est pour d'autres comme
question oui et il est clair que les
gouvernements comme les opérateurs
financiers ont pris depuis quinze jours
maintenant simplement la mesure de ce
qui est en train de se passer
alors évidemment ça a eu des
conséquences importantes sur les bourses
mais pas que on a vu que le prix des
matières premières a aussi fortement
baissé en particulier le pétrole et
campsas expliqué bien globalement tout
le monde pensait que c'était une
épidémie comme celle du sras en 2003
sauf qu'en réalité le virus est beaucoup
plus contagieux que le virus du strass
on a des fois plus de malades au moins
rien que pour la chine
par ailleurs le poids de la chine est
beaucoup plus important que ce qu'il
était en 2003 donc tout concourt à faire
que dans une économie qui aujourd'hui
est plus fragile
en réalité qu'en 2003 et bien tout
concourt à ce que l'on n'ait une crise
mondiale
alors avant toute chose jacquat je vous
propose de regarder les réactions des
personnes que nous avons interrogé sur
les risques que fait peser se dégage
on est tous à alerte à ce qui se passe
notamment sur les marchés boursiers on a
tous été alerte à la chute vertigineuse
des cotations américaine et dans une
moindre mesure européenne au niveau de
mes placements il ya eu
une grosse baisse puisque les marchés
mondiaux ont réagi la chine étant au
coeur de l'épidémie
c'est les marchés chinois qui ont
beaucoup baissé mais de manière générale
tous les marchés on essaie tous les
émergents la première chose c'est de ne
pas paniquer parce qu'effectivement
aussi vous vendez vos actions et que
demain vos collègues vont des actions
par définition tout le monde va vendre
ses actions les vagues déplacements sont
très limités et à l'heure actuelle on
prépare donc des solutions telles que le
pc a donc des plans de continuité
d'activité pour travailler de chez nous
pour éviter la propagation du virus et
ses impacts sur tous les événements en
fait sur lesquels on doit participer en
france il ya un maximum d'événements qui
sont annulés nous ont battus revivent
attaque en juin et on a peur que ça soit
annulée à cause du vent est violent je
pense pas que corona virus peut être à
l'origine d'une d'une récession globale
de l'économie
ça peut être un élément déclencheur je
pense n'est pas le facteur principal la
paranoïa peut provoquer la crise
économique peut doubler la crise
sanitaire d'une telle crise économique
maintenant si la population continue à
garder ces mêmes habitudes économique à
maintenir son niveau de consommation la
donne ne devrait pas changer et je sais
déjà qui a plusieurs entreprises qui
rocky se disent qu'ils vont peut-être
rapatrier les usines en france ou au
moins une partie de la production en
france en espagne ou en allemagne
justement parce que tout est bloqué en
chine pour une durée d'un an
indéterminée c'est pour ça que je dis
que c'est bien aussi parce que ça fait
que des grosses entreprises commencent à
se poser des questions votre réaction
chaque bien c'est très intéressant parce
que on voit que les gens qui ont été
interrogés ont conscience qu'ils se
passe quelque chose
alors après il attribue plus de poids au
marché chinois coc marchés occidentaux
roll le cac40 le dow jones et puis
surtout il ya une espèce comme toujours
de méconnaissance des chaînes de
propagation réel de cette crise alors
jacques il y a eu
ces derniers jours un mini krach
boursier que s'est il passé concrètement
alors ce qui s'est passé depuis
maintenant à peu près une quinzaine de
jours c'est que les opérateurs
financiers
les spécialistes des marchés eh bien ils
ont pris conscience qu'il y avait un
problème avec le coronavirus que
l'économie chinoise
elle était quasiment à l'arrêt on le
savait on le savait depuis la fin du
mois de janvier
mais là ils en ont pris réellement
conscience il a fallu pour cela qu'il y
ait cette fameuse statistique qui est
tombé le 20 février les la consommation
d'énergie en chine est à 38 % 38 %
seulement du niveau qu'elle était
l'année dernière alors évidemment ça eu
des des impacts extrêmement 1% sur l'
indice du cac 40 qui s'est effondré un
rapidement qui au début de la semaine
est un petit peu remonté mais qui depuis
jeudi est en train là encore de
rebaisser il y a un le dow jones qui
suit grosso modo le même chemin alors le
dow jones qui était au delà de 29500
donc un plus haut historique et qui
chute très brutalement avant de repartir
à la hausse mais de rechuter encore un
petit peu après et donc là on voit bien
qu'il ya un problème sérieux
alors jacques comment cela
s'explique-t-il
je voulais dit c'est en fait des
opérateurs qui vivent dans une forme de
déni de réalité qui considère que bon
quand la virus oui ça église mais ça
n'aura pas de conséquences économiques
et qui tout d'un coup comprennent que
ben voilà avec l'économie chinoise à
l'arrêt ça ne peut qu'avoir des
conséquences économiques extrêmement
importante
alors ce phénomène est-il limité aux
seuls indices boursiers non non il ya
évidemment la question des matières
premières vous savez quand une économie
est quasiment à l'arrêt ou disons à 20 %
de sa capacité de production normal et
bien évidemment elle achète beaucoup
moins de matière première et ça se voit
sur les cours du pétrole
voyez là on appris lundi du baril de
brent
alors le baril de brent il était monté
il ya un mois à peu près oh
pour 2 64 65 dollars pour un baril il
est tombé depuis là le milieu de cette
semaine
grosso modo entre 49 et 50 dollars c'est
très important parce que ça aussi un
impact sur je dirais la solvabilité de
toutes les entreprises américaines qui
exploite le pétrole de schiste alors
jacques
qu'est ce qui explique cette
sous-estimation jusqu'ici de l'impact du
corps d'un virus et bien
fondamentalement les opérateurs
financiers même chose pour les
gouvernements d'ailleurs n'ont pas
compris que le poids des économies
avaient fortement changé depuis 2003 en
2003 la chine ne peser que huit et demi
pour cent du pib mondial
les etats unis s'étaient 20% et on avait
un reste du monde qui était pratiquement
à 60% aujourd'hui plus exactement en
2019 eh bien on à la chine qui est à
plus de 19%
les etats-unis qui ne sont qu'à 15% la
chine est bien passé devant les états
unis
mais ça se fait aussi au détriment du
reste du monde parce qu'il ya d'autres
pays
un qui progresse comme l'un est donc
cela renforce la jirs est le caractère
central de l'économie chinoise
alors est-ce qu'on va considérer dans
ces conditions que la france va être
touché ah oui il est tout à fait évident
qu'il va y avoir des conséquences
économiques importantes sur la france
alors pour plusieurs raisons d'abord la
chine ne peut plus fournir de pièces à
assembler à de nombreuses entreprises
françaises
les clients chinois vont baisser leurs
achats en france ou en provenance de
france on a aussi le problème du
tourisme
le problème du transport aérien mais il
ya un autre problème c'est que des
économies comme l'économie allemande
l'économie italienne qui vendait
beaucoup en chine elle aussi elle se
retrouve là avec un impact très sévère
de cette crise or nous avons des
relations économiques extrêmement
intense avec ces pays
l'allemand
et traditionnellement notre premier
partenaire donc si nos partenaires sont
malades
on ne peut pas avait bien nous mêmes et
il est intéressant de voir que l' ocde a
fait à réviser plus exactement ses
prévisions alors que l' ocde prévoyait
une croissance de 1,2 pour cent pour
2020 aujourd'hui il ne prévoit plus que
0 9% et la question qu'on se pose
jacques quel va être l'impact réel sur
l'industrie française et européenne
alors cet impact sera certainement
important je voulais parler évidemment
de ces pièces que l'on importe de chine
peut-être pour faire autre chose aussi
mais que l'on importe de chine et qu'on
ne peut plus avoir
mais vous savez il ya comme ça des
chiffres qui sont intéressantes prenons
le cas des matériels de construire des
matériels de transport bon les
importations directes de chine
c'est pas énorme c'est 1,6 milliard
d'euros
mais quand on regarde les importations
qui viennent des autres pays de l'union
européenne 60 milliards d'euros
là ça fait beaucoup ça fait grosso modo
3 % de notre produit intérieur brut dans
ces 60 milliards il ya 3 % de choses qui
sont produites en chine
autrement dit ce ne sont pas simplement
les importations chinoises qui vont en
bessin qui veut qu'ils se sont ils dit
mais c'est l'ensemble des chaînes de
production qui sont aujourd'hui touchés
y compris dans des pays qui pour
l'instant ne sont pas touchés par le
corona veilleuse je dis bien pour
l'instant parce que quand on voit ce qui
se passe en italie on comprend qu'il va
y avoir aussi des problèmes l'industrie
talent et il faut le rappeler elle est
essentiellement lombardi alors jaloux
vous nous aviez parlé il ya trois
semaines on s'en souvient des
médicaments qu'on est il oui tout le
monde je sais aujourd'hui entre 60 et
80% des principes actifs des médicaments
sont produits que ce soit en chine où
que ce soit en inde ce qui d'ailleurs
pose un véritable problème de
souveraineté pharmaceutique
à la fin il est clair là que l'arrêt ou
disons le très fort ralentissement de la
production chinoise va avoir un impact
mais par ailleurs regardez cette courbe
elle est très intéressante
il s'agit des importations chinoises en
produits pharmaceutiques en matériel de
or en 2005 grosso modo au moment de
l'épidémie du strass et bien il y avait
entre 75 et 76 % de la valeur qui
étaient faites en chine donc ce qu'il a
dit qu'il y avait autour de 25% qui
était fait à l'étranger hors de chine
aujourd'hui on est à 85%
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que non seulement les produits chinois
sont importants dans les importations
que nous achetons hors de chine par
exemple dans l'union européenne aux
états unis mais que les produits chinois
eux mêmes comme l'avant des importations
directes de la chine devienne entre
guillemets de plus en plus chinois et ça
c'est un très bon indicateur justement
de ce poids de la chine
alors jacques vous nous dresser un quand
même un tableau particulièrement sombre
à un peu plus longtemps même il faut
bien le dire va-t-on comme on se demande
de plus en plus vers un remake de la
grande crise de 2008 selon vous alors
d'abord il s'agit pas d'être pessimiste
optimiste et j'ai simplement d'être
réalise alors oui le problème de ce qui
se passe sur les marchés financiers il
est sérieux il est sérieux pourquoi
parce que ça veut dire que la des
entreprises des banques aussi peuvent
connaître des gros problèmes de
liquidités d'ores et déjà les banques
françaises ont été très durement attaqué
en milieu de semaine et donc ça veut
dire qu'il faudra qu'il y ait une action
spécifique des banques centrales pour
les soutenir
au-delà de cette action des banques
centrales parce qu'on va très vite voir
que les banques centrales ne peuvent pas
tout faire
vous savez la réserve fédérale
américaine elle a baissé son taux
directeur de 0 5% tournée de 50 points
pas maintenant qu'est ce qu'elle peut
faire elle peut encore le baisser de
nouveau 50 ans et puis elle sera à zéro
elle va payer les gens pour que me pour
leur prêter oui bien il ya véritablement
la même chose avec la bce donc ça veut
dire que aujourd'hui les capacités
d'action des banques centrales sont en
réalité plus réduite que ce qu'elle
était à la veille de la crise de 2008
et c'est ça justement l'un des soucis
que l'on a
si on a la combinaison d'une crise dans
la production à laquelle les banques
centrales ne peuvent rien mais aussi de
problèmes alors par exemple bancaire
vous allez avoir plein d'entreprises qui
comme elles ne produisent plus comme
elles ne vendent plus ne pourront pas
rembourser leurs emprunts ne pourront
pas payer leurs intérêts donc si on a la
combinaison de ce problème réel et de ce
problème financier
il se pourrait bien que le coronavirus
provoque en réalité une crise du même
ordre que la crise de 2008 et on peut
dire si vous n'êtes que autant la crise
de 2008
c'était la crise de la finance
globalisée c'était parti de titres
pourris américain autant là la crise du
corona diam's c'est la véritable crise
de la mondialisation
merci je ne sais pas si je dois vous
remercier d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de nous
avoir plombé notre moral merci je suis
désolé en tout cas ça donne à réfléchir
à très bientôt